paraded in front of cameras and told
they can go home
these are some of the 350 prisoners
released by yemen's houthi rebels
it's an overwhelming sense of delight
happiness and pleasure
as i am coming home back to my family
we hope for the release of all prisoners
and detainees from all sides simply
because we are yemenis and all the
prisoners and their families are
suffering
they were on the lists drawn under a u.n
brokered prisoner swap agreement
signed in stockholm in december the deal
to release seven thousand detainees was
seen as a breakthrough through words
peace
but the yemeni government and the
houthis have blamed each other for
failing to implement
it houthi rebels say this unconditional
release should show their commitment
we are prepared and willing for an
all-inclusive swap deal whether they are
yemenis or other nationalities
and to prove our sincerity we have
initiated the unconditional release of
350 prisoners
we have called the united nations to
pressure the other side to reciprocate
among those being held are saudi
citizens who the houthis say will be
handed to the red cross
aid workers have called for gestures
like this as a way to build confidence
with hopes that it can lead to a
peaceful resolution the people who were
released today were
fathers sons brothers of course we hope
to see more
initiatives in the future bigger numbers
from all sides
and as the international committee of
the red cross we are always ready to act
as a neutral facilitator just as we did
today
in any future release operation so
definitely we are hopeful
and we also hope that this release revi
uh
contributes to the revival of the
stockholm agreement
in a media briefing on monday the
spokesman for the saudi uae coalition
was non-committal on releasing captives
in response to the houthis freeing
hundreds of fighters
according to the houthi military
spokesman they launched a major attack
inside the saudi territory of najiran
and destroyed multiple vehicles as well
houthi rebels showed the capture of
hundreds of yemeni and saudi soldiers
which al-jazeera cannot independently
verify
the saudi spokesman also cautioned
against taking these videos at face
value
it's part of a series of attacks
including the one on saudi aramco which
took out half of its oil production
earlier this month
the houthis criticized world power for
condemning the attack
and said oil is a commodity which is not
more expensive than yemeni blood
it is an escalation of violence in a war
that many see as a proxy conflict
between iran and saudi arabia osama bin
laden
al jazeera